welcome to a very very special event in
the history of Carnegie Mellon when we
formally dedicate and light the randy
pausch Memorial Bridge I want to extend
a special welcome to Virginia pouch
Randy's mother J pouch J pouch Randy's
wife and their kids still in logan and
chloe Randy's sister Tammy basin and her
daughters Laura wooly and McKay Joe
Mason well tonight you're still a son
sorry that I've had occasion I I really
am sorry about it they get mine get me
wrong sometimes too and other family
members were so delighted that so many
of Randy's family could be here for this
special occasion Houston one
acknowledged at Jeff zaslow Randy's
co-author of the last lecture book and
according about alumnus and Jeff and an
alumni achievement award winner just
before we came over here is also with
this tonight Jeff you want to raise your
hand
this bridge is significant a lot of ways
it's significant because in a very real
sense it completes the gates Hillman
computer science complex it creates a
physical connection literally between
the gates and human centers to the pre
Nell center but also creates a
connection between the cut and the
instance this may be now known as the
upper campus I don't know we don't have
words yet you have to develop the words
will be using in the future connecting
the cut up here to the new quad down
there the connection that never existed
before to acquire that never really
existed before through a building that
just opened two months ago and without
question this is going to be a major
thoroughfare and the randy pausch bridge
will be the way you get back and forth
of course the bridge memorializes randy
and is devotion to connections
connections between the arts and
computer science in a very physical and
tangible way but it's just one of the
many parts of Randy's legacy that are
with us still and will be with this for
a long time to come there is the Alice
program the programming environment that
uses 3d 3d graphics and animation to
teach introductory computing by the way
something that keeps expanding in terms
of its users and just issued a new
version recently there's the building
virtual worlds course which Randy
starting still lives on in the able
hands of Jesse Schell and others still
one of the most popular courses on
campus and still one of the highlights
of the year is going to the bvw show at
the end of the semester and in a way
it's one of those Randy
head fakes when students think they're
learning about building virtual worlds
which they are they're really learning
about energy sperry collaboration and
how to get along with each other
something that randy was so keen on and
of course as a entertainment Technology
Center which Randy co-founded and which
has been such an enormous success the
success that keeps growing both through
its students and alumni and the
fantastic research and games that they
create and there's a last lecture itself
that lives on in both video in a book
form that's been read and viewed by tens
of millions of people around the world
and they will continue to these are
wonderful the bridge these parts of
Randy's legacy but of course we all know
they're just products or symbols or
programs that represent Randy but of
course they're not the person that we
love and in turn the person who loved
Carnegie Mellon so much I do want to say
something about the bridge itself and
you'll experience it for yourself in a
moment but I want you to understand some
of the thinking that went into it and a
lot of deep thought and creativity went
into this bridge in designing it we try
to capture the things that Randy cared
most about and to represent some of his
lessons as captured in his last lecture
first of all the bridge runs high in the
air higher than it has to actually
trying to convey the notion of Randy's
lofty ideas and aspirations you'll see
penguins etched into the railing in a
stylistic way and that captures Randy's
first penguin notion the first penguin
award made so famous both in his book in
its course an award a concept to
symbolize that person brave enough to be
the first one into the predator infested
water
someone who's willing to take a chance
you will see the Magnificent lights that
are a key part of this bridge lights
that are well they'll speak for
themselves i won't try to describe them
but they capture both art and science a
sense of wonder and Randy's wonderful
sense of playfulness another part about
him we love so much and he be delighted
that they're completely programmable and
environmentally friendly of course I
want to thank several people I want to
thank the many donors who made this
bridge possible I want to thank the
architects who really gave their heart
and blood sweat and tears to figure out
a design that would capture Randy and
memorialize him appropriately the
architects sir max Coggan and Marilyn
Elam the same people that designed the
gates and Holman centers and their team
especially Kimberly shoemaker Medlock
who also worked on the buildings I want
to acknowledge the construction team
cliff Rao and his company PJ dick Mike
Hanlon and his company handled like
electric and chris roling and his
company Keystone medals I want to thank
the many colleagues at randys who
conceived of the bridge thought of
naming it for him in the first place and
worked so hard to make it happen Randy
Bryant the D in the computer science
school guide block the great coordinator
for faculty input in school input in
design of the buildings and Jim skis
their longtime facilities manager I want
to thank and acknowledge the campus
design and construction group led by
Ralph organ Joe greenaway whose project
this was and who put so much of himself
into it and Andrew Riley and I want to
thank our marvelous University
Advancement group for all that they did
to make this possible
and the company Color Kinetics now part
of Philips electronic electronics and
especially Kevin Dowling our alumnus who
did so much to make it possible for us
to get the lighting absolutely
state-of-the-art lighting that is in the
bridge and I want to acknowledge our
brilliant faculty who are the lighting
designers of the show you'll see in a
moment Sidney Lamar oh and her partner
and husband Chris Popovich they designed
the show and like all of us they were
inspired by Randy in the last lecture
all of these people saw this as a labor
of love and they were thrilled to do it
those of you who are athol at the last
lecture know that at the end I announced
that this bridge would be built and
that'll be named for Randy something
that we know granny was delighted by and
I said to Randy that after he was gone
there would come generations students
who did not know him and could not have
known and I promised him then that we
would tell them about Randy so that they
would know what a special person he was
and what enormous impact he had on this
university and therefore on them the
bridge is the fulfillment of that
promise because every person who walks
across it will be reminded of Randy the
bright shining light he was in our lives
they'll see the plaques that we've
erected and the other symbolism and
we'll make them understand a little bit
to the extent that you can and without
having no no Randy Pausch and some of
the things that he stood for
that's why this bridge means so much to
us
you